there's real concerns about violence in
this election how can you guarantee that
your support supporters won't incite
violence if you don't win
we have made it absolutely clear in fact
we have a solid track record
of not ever engaging in violence but you
were investigated by the icc for
violence in the two and that is why we
were acquitted because these were issues
that were raised that were irrelevant in
fact the people who should have been
asked those questions are the people who
are candidates in that election
neither president kibaki no no ray
lauringa were asked in fact they are the
ones who
said
uh for the country to be stable they
should not be investigated in in fact
the people below them should be
investigated but finally we were
acquitted because we were innocent
people
what i'm asking the country i've asked
all my supporters
because we have
since 2013
president uhuru kenyatta and i
took the country on a path of
reconciliation of working together and
we made a commitment to this country
that we will do whatever it takes for
this country never again to go the path
of
violence
and in the last two elections we
succeeded
there was an attempt by my current
competitor to drive the country in that
direction he did not succeed i don't
think he will succeed in this election
i have made a commitment
that um
whatever the outcome of this election i
will accept the results what guarantees
do we have that your supporters will
remain peaceful if you don't win this
election
of course and supporters are always
peaceful
but in 2007 at least a thousand people
were killed when you lost the election
but that was because the elections were
rigged
my people were
dissatisfied
they were not the ones who actually was
the violence
because i know that was shoot to kill
by the government at that time
so our people was basically just
reacting in self-defense
but my people are always spiritual will
you accept that outcome if you lose sir
i've just said he's there
he must speak
they will accept
and congratulate the winner
if he wins fairly
and also expect him to do the same thing
how do you plan to engage with the young
people in this country kenya is a very
very young country
of course you know i've got a lot of
support from the youth
i understand their problems
i know their concerns
those are the ones that you're going to
address
and my government is going to have a lot
of youth
in it
they're going to give a lot of
opportunities to young kids
and how will you improve the economy and
help with the cost of living
crisis
we know the problem
you know the cause of it
we also know the solution
they are
short-term measures that we are going to
take
to alleviate the suffering of the people
you